dimanche dernier le magazine sept à huit
s'est intéressé aux réseaux sociaux mais
cette fois ci bien loin de l'image
léchée paradisiaque parfois véhiculée
sur ces médias le magazine s'est
intéressé à la face cachée de ces
réseaux benmouloud qui font parfois
l'objet de chantage ou de vengeance sur
les réseaux sociaux sur ces réseaux
notamment snap château instagram de
nombreux adolescents échange des news
des photos et vidéos sexuelles des
contenus qui peut faire ensuite l'objet
de chantage donc il m'a dit mais
coûteuse si tu veux tu m'envoies une
photo de tessin lors de cours
d'éducation de sexologues a tenté
d'avertir les plus jeunes sur ces
phénomènes mais aussi de leur enseigner
la notion de consentement parce que
j'avais entendu parler d'une personne
quand on est reçu au qu'aurait envoyé
des news une génération très exposées à
ces dangers inédit face auquel les
parents sont parfois démunis un sujet
qui a intéressé 2 6 millions de
téléspectateurs
merci de votre fidélité alors sept à
huit reportages chocs sur les dangers
des réseaux sociaux choquée
choqué oui non oui égalé par également
vous êtes dans les réseaux du matin au
soir et du soir au matin
oui je suis complètement choqué
évidemment parce qu'on peut pas dire ne
peut pas dire c'est normal
c'est un constat g je crois que c'est
interdit aux enfants de moins de 13 ans
normalement et qu'on doit être gérée par
les parents et ce doit être signalée sur
leur compte c'est à dire que moi ma
fille m'ont obligé à m géré par le comte
de madame magali berda la maman tu sais
ça c'est obligatoire s'ils ne peuvent
suspendre les comptes ce qu'ils ont fait
à mon hôte 6 11 ans qui s'est fait
sauter son compte sur instagram n'a plus
de comptes parce que bâle avait retiré
cette motion et c'est très bien ça c'est
vraiment très bien de protéger mais faut
aller beaucoup plus loin parce
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas assez de
protection sur les réseaux faut se
battre il ya des enfants qui sont
victimes moi j'ai une petite un jour qui
m'a contacté pareil parce qu'elle
s'était fait pirater son snapper souvent
il y en a qui envoient des vidéos des
petites photos d'elle à leurs copines
par exemple est en fait le problème
c'est que j'en arrive à pirater les snap
et à rentrer dans toutes les vidéos et
c'est là où il ya un problème parce
qu'après on reçoit des messages de
menaces et chantage donc même si la
petite ou le petit et discret même si
les parents contrôlent pas le problème
c'est qu'il ya des hackers qui vont
piraté les comptes mais qui vont après
les utiliser pour leur mettre de
pression j'ai une question et je vous ai
posé des regrets d'amour quand on ouvre
un compte de jeux en ligne en vous
demande une facture edf je vous demande
une copie du passeport on vous demande
deux ou trois documents justifiant ce
déficit est de la ville habités pourquoi
on fais pas ça sur l'airé instagram et
tik tok ça réglerait le problème des
années mais pas sans réglementer la
voilà il a fait rien alors je vous donne
la réponse parce que forcément terre
d'argence sur les jeux en ligne l'état
prend du blé n'est sûr de rien tu vois
ça le vrai problème des pouvoirs publics
français que ces kits sont impuissants
face à l'encadrement des réseaux sociaux
il faut dire que les gars fassent ce
qu'ils gèrent ces réseaux sociaux sont
américains dont ils appliquent leurs
propres règles ce qu'il faudrait c'est
un c'est ça des réseaux sociaux que sa
forêt t
on un bond à 1 mais non non mais un
régulateur parce que oui il ya un
excellent documentaire sur fx appel
derrière nos écrans de fumée il donne la
parole justement aux responsables des
gaffes à et je pense que c'est vraiment
aux parents de se responsabiliser
également pour se rendre compte qu à la
fois passé un temps limité sur les
réseaux sociaux désactivez notification
c'est peu de chose à avoir finalement
c'est vrai que moi je pense que ça peut
devenir un problème oui il est important
de leur dire vraiment vraiment mais ça
ça me tient à coeur et ça tient à coeur
à tous tous les parents il faut prévenir
les adolescents ou même les plus jeunes
à ne pas envoyer à qui que ce soit à
quiconque des nude ou des vidéos un
petit peu sexy tu veux dire ça c'est pas
faut pas le faire vraiment je le répète
il faut pas le faire parce que quoi
qu'il arrive un jour ou l'autre ça va
leur retomber dessus et on a un
témoignage d'ailleurs de 2 par an et que
c'est l'équipe des conséquences avec son
moment on n'y pense pas et savait
qu'après ça pour sortir et c'est valable
d'ailleurs pour les ados et aussi pour
les adultes oui oui bien sûr
pour nous gâcher je pensais pas qu'à 14
ans pouvait faire ce genre de choses
j'avais une de ma fille on ne l'avait
pas élevé
comme ça quoi on tombe des nues
aussi comment on a pu passer à côté quoi
comment est ce qu'on a fait pour passer
à côté de sa plage en armes en question
les services en question mettait plus
avancé plus armés que nous l'étions
elle la culpabiliser plus qu'elle a
déformé en tant que victime je pense
sincèrement que s'il y avait une
réglementation très précises pour
l'ouverture faite par les parents il y
aurait beaucoup moins beaucoup imprégné